in the wake of two mass shootings that
would not have been prevented by any of
the gun control legislation proposed in
recent years Republicans and Democrats
are coming together to endorse you
guessed it more gun control legislation
that will not stop any future shootings
but hey at least the laws will infringe
on our constitutional rights we will
analyze the many red flags in red flag
laws then the mainstream Left keeps up
it's defamatory temper tantrum we'll
look at a few examples of that what it
means for 2020 what it means for our
political future finally conservative
environmentalist Benjie backer stops by
to try to turn me green good luck buddy
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
red flags and green conservatives yes
we've got a whole slew the whole rainbow
of politics today I want to start with
red flag laws because unfortunately it
seems the president conservatives in
Congress and obviously the entirety of
the far-left
did not watch my show yesterday they
just didn't listen I hate to say I told
you so particularly on this topic but I
pointed out yesterday that all of the
reaction particularly on the left to
these two awful shootings over the
weekend has been emotivist it has been
grounded in raw emotion the slander the
temper tantrums the political attacks
that have come out of it have not been
grounded in reality have not been
grounded in crime statistics have not
been grounded in legislation that
actually would change anything there it
is just this raw emotional response and
I feared as I have seen my fears
vindicated that conservatives in the
desire to be seen as doing something
would allow their emotions to run away
with them and embrace gun control laws
that would not have stopped the attacks
and will not stop future attacks turns
out I was right you know after the last
few mass shootings the Conservatives did
a pretty good job of thinking with their
heads and not just thinking with their
overheated emotions this one was
different I guess I don't know why but
for some reason this one has
conservatives backing gun control so
what are the gun control laws that get
proposed when there are mass shootings
they always talk about banning assault
weapons and obviously there's no such
thing as an assault weapon all weapons
are assault weapons the term was made up
in the 1980s to confuse people who don't
understand the difference between an
automatic fully automatic assault rifle
which have been banned in this country
for decades and regular old guns where
you pull the trigger once and one bullet
comes out which is true of pistols it's
true of revolvers it's true of the ar-15
and every other rifle in between that
you can get in the open market so they
talk about banning assault weapons I
don't think that's really going to go
anywhere I don't think there's an
appetite for that we know that it these
so-called assault weapons
or involved in very very few shootings
per year very very few homicides the
vast vast majority of homicide and
suicide of gun deaths per year come from
handguns 22 times more than 22 times the
number of deaths that include rifles of
any sort including the so-called assault
weapons so I think the assault weapons
ban is dead on arrival then there's the
question of banning handguns which are
obviously involved in the vast majority
of gun related deaths per year that
isn't going to happen why because it's
unconstitutional there they tried to ban
handguns in DC that was overturned in
the Heller decision you have a second
Amendment right to a gun and if they're
not going to ban handguns then they're
not going to address the problem the the
problem of gun related deaths so then
you get to the question of a
constitutional amendment which is what
the left really wants what the really
the left really wants to do is just gut
the Second Amendment take away your
individual right to keep and bear arms
which we've had in this country since
the very beginning and since we which
which we inherited from English law I
don't think they're gonna do that I
don't think there's any support for that
even among many Democrats who represent
red states ain't going to happen so then
we get to this legislation which
everybody is endorsing and that is red
flag laws why are red flag laws popular
right now you've got a Donald Trump
saying that he supports red flag laws
you've got Lindsey Graham saying he
supports red flag laws he's working with
Democrat dick Blumenthal the guy who
lied about his Vietnam War Service to
endorse red flag laws why is this
gaining support it's gaining support
because people don't know what it is
it's kind of sounds good like all of
these pieces of gun control legislation
it sounds good in theory yeah if they're
red flags we don't want that guy to have
a gun and so they're getting behind it
also because it hasn't been in the
public view for a long time so people
don't know why they're so bad right now
seventeen states have approved some
version of a red flag law that includes
Florida New York Connecticut Illinois
Indiana and California before the
Marjory Stoneman Douglas shooting last
year at the in Broward County at that
high school there were
five states that had these laws so red
flag laws are gaining steam over the
past year and they don't work is the
trouble so one of the earliest states to
pass a red flag law was Connecticut they
passed red flag laws in in 1999 and
obviously one of the deadliest mass
shootings at a school happened thirteen
years later at Sandy Hook now what do
red flag laws do they say that if there
are red flags in a person's history you
know their behavior what they're writing
they're getting in trouble at school
they're posting things on the internet
it's pretty nebulous then you can bring
that kid before a judge and the judge
can deem him incapable of holding a gun
and take away his constitutional right
to own a gun in certain states the the
parents can haul their kids or family
members can haul their crazy uncle you
know before the judge and say he
shouldn't have his constitutional right
to own a gun and the judge can say okay
that's fine and then this is regularly
brought back up and this lack of a
constitutional right can be extended
basically in perpetuity why is this so
bad
I'm not against taking guns away from
crazy people I don't think crazy people
should be able to get guns and we do
have a problem in this country of crazy
people getting guns but it should be
very very very difficult to take away
someone's right to have a gun why
because the right to own a gun is not
the same as the right to drive a car
driving a car is a privilege owning a
gun is your civil right it is your
Second Amendment right it is right there
in the Constitution so how should we
make it such that you can take away guns
from crazy people we'll get to that in a
second but first I have to thank our
friends over at ancestry.com and I love
ancestry I have been a longtime client
of ancestry and a longtime customer
because I love history I was a history
major my grandfather has spent years and
years researching our genealogy and I
love it you ever wonder where your
family comes from you can discover more
about them and learn more about your
history by combining the ancestry DNA
test with billions of historical family
records so I've already done my ancestry
DNA test it's very easy to spit in a
little tube you mail it in and it tells
you all about all about your background
which kind of surprising to me I found
out that I'm actually
more British than Italian big surprise
to my swarthy skin in oily hair but it
turns out I'm slightly more British than
Italian the ancestry test is only one
part of it because then you can go back
and connect it with all of these
historical records I mean I found out I
have four ancestors from the Mayflower
we can trace that all the way back
ancestors who fought in the American
Revolution alongside George Washington
who went to Valley Forge or Bunker Hill
I mean you can get all the sorts sorts
of stuff and it goes back very very far
they've combined DNA results with over
100 million family trees and billions of
records to give you more insight into
your genealogy and origins only ancestry
can tell you such a rich story with
unique features that give a more
complete picture about the person that
is in your tree the person that you are
because of all those people before you
you can find out how your ancestor has
become more than just a name and it's
very easy to get started right now go to
ancestry.com today you will get 20% off
your ancestry DNA kit that is
ancestry.com for 20% off your ancestry
DNA kit ancestry.com go over there check
it out you get 20% off and it is super
cool it's like my favorite hobby go
check it out right now
so I think we should be able to take
guns away from crazy people totally
believe that red flag laws are not the
way to do it it should not be the same
as taking away someone's right to drive
a car you know if you get too many
speeding tickets you they can take away
your driver's license because you don't
have a civil right to a driver's license
you know the constitutional right to
drive a car so it's easier to take away
that right guns are different you have a
civil right to a gun so if we're going
to take away people's civil rights you
got to go for it you got to really go
for you should basically not be able to
take away someone's right to own a gun
unless you are willing to throw them in
a padded room and lock the door put them
in a straitjacket take away their right
to vote take away their right to live on
their own take away their right to work
and and be a part of polite society on
their own I'm fine I think we should be
able to do that this ties
with the mental health aspect of all of
these mass shootings we don't have a
system in this country anymore to lock
up crazy people who were a danger to
themselves and a danger to others we
should have that it was very well
intentioned when we got rid of the
insane asylums we got rid of them in
large part because of the development of
psychiatric drugs whereby people would
take them and they would stop being
crazy they would get even they would be
able to behave in in normal society
trouble is that once they got out of the
inside lumps they stopped taking the
drugs they wind up on the street they
wind up a danger to themselves and to
others we went way too far in that
direction many of the pioneers of
closing down the asylums now regret it
because we love way too many people at
we need to make it easier in this
country to involuntarily commit people
when you involuntarily commit people you
are taking away their civil rights but
this is not an infringement on their
Liberty because when you are insane you
are not capable of Liberty you need to
be sane in order to access your freedom
otherwise you've become a slave to
passions and in into lunacy what the
left wants to do though they don't want
to go all that way they don't want to
follow those ideas to their logical
conclusions because they don't really
view guns as a civil right they don't
really view your Second Amendment rights
as a core civil right they view it as
this unfortunate vestigial part of the
Constitution and they want to get rid of
it and so they're gonna chip away at it
slowly and consistently don't let them
do that and and conservatives shouldn't
fall for this whether it's the president
whether it's senators whether it's your
rank-and-file conservative fine you want
to do something that's the quote you
know do something do something to fix
the shootings do something even if it
won't stop the shootings do something
like pass red flag laws which did not
stop the shootings in those states where
those laws were passed fine don't don't
stop halfway though don't let them have
their cake and eat it too if you want to
take away people's civil rights take
away their civil rights but but don't
lie to me and and only take away the
civil rights you want to take away but
but not all of the others that doesn't
make any sense it's pretty dangerous
it's unconstitutional though if you want
to take away people's civil rights
make a serious argument for it they're
not going to do it though because there
aren't serious arguments to be made here
the left is not making serious arguments
they're having a temper tantrum you saw
this over the past few days we talked
about it yesterday it's still going on
here on MSNBC is MSNBC host Nicole
Wallace making her big or is her big
argument about white supremacy and the
threat it poses to the country her big
argument is the President Trump is
talking about exterminating Latinos here
she is certainly the last Republican
President fought for thought and and and
it's not an ideal but had 44% right
Latino vote it was so politically
powerful and inside the last for public
administration President Obama used the
power of the presidency to try to pass
comprehensive immigration reform with
the Latino community Latino leaders at
the table you know have a president as
you said talking about exterminating
right Latinas
do you have that president is that the
president you've got I could you show me
that clip hey control room show me that
clip where Trump talks about
exterminating Latinos do we have it oh
we don't have it because obviously
that's never happened that is a fever
dream inside the ridiculous fantasies of
this MSNBC host so she had to walk this
back he even MSNBC has a certain level
of shame I guess and this is her walking
aback quote I misspoke about Trump
calling for an extermination of Latinos
my mistake was unintentional and I'm
sorry
Trump's constant assault on people of
color and his use of the word invasion
to describe the flow of immigrants is
intentional and constant okay so it's
obviously not not an apology at all she
in the second part says Trump is a
really bad guy and he uses the term
invasion to describe an invasion of
people not people of color by the way
we're talking about illegal aliens who
actually are invading the country
because they're foreign nationals but I
love this first part I misspoke about
Trump calling for an extermination of
Latinos my mistake was unintentional and
I'm sorry how many times have you
accidentally accused someone of genocide
good does that is that a regular thing
that people do sorry I you know it's
like a Freudian slip where you say one
thing but you mean your mother
then you accuse her of genocide no
that's not how it works she knew exactly
what she was doing she's not sorry for
it and she's not apologizing for it
that's MSNBC for you but maybe we should
expect that of MSNBC I mean that is an
hysterical Channel where the furthest
left numbskulls go on to spread their
lies we should not be able to expect
that from presidential candidates and US
senators and yet that's what we got so
Cory Booker senator spartacus spewing
tears of rage needs to try to get his
poll numbers up and so he's accusing the
president of being white supremacists a
white nationalist a white bigot or
whatever you know what whatever the term
du jour is to to malign your political
opponents now while ago Cory Booker was
asked on CNN about this white supremacy
question he said President Trump needs
to call out white supremacy he needs to
condemn white supremacy so what does
President Trump do he condemns white
supremacy they ask Cory Booker about
this is that good enough of course it is
not good enough senator Spartacus
himself and for him to fail even to
condemn Nazis or even to talk about
white supremacy is a problem in this
country to me that is being complicit in
the violence that is happening senator
another thing that the president said in
his remarks today I'll read it to you he
said in one voice our nation must
condemn racism bigotry and white
supremacy do you welcome that
acknowledgement no no of course I don't
because what Cory Booker wants is for
President Trump to be a Nazi because
that's his narrative that's the story
he's telling and it doesn't matter the
president Trump consistently it seems
like every few weeks for the past three
years it says I condemn racism racism is
evil hatred warps the soul it gnaws away
at the soul it's awful we're Americans
we share the same blood of patriotism
where I go on and on and on I mean we
could spend a whole show playing those
clips but in Cory Booker's mind Trump is
a neo-nazi so that when when Trump says
things that contradict that narrative he
hates it he doesn't welcome that he
doesn't really want Trump to condemn it
at all pretty pathetic but you know what
cory booker is a desperate presidential
candidate who is going nowhere he's not
going to be president we
have the brother of another presidential
candidate Joaquin Castro who's the
brother of who Leon Castro
Joaquin Castro is a sitting congressman
and he took it a step further he's not
just running his mouth with these stupid
fantasies and these stupid smears he's
actually going out in nearly daxing his
own constituents this was a tweet sad to
see so many Sant Antoni ins as 2019
maximum donors to Donald Trump the owner
of Bill Miller barbecue the owner of
historic pearl realtor Phyllis browning
etc their contributions are fueling a
campaign of hate that labels Hispanic
immigrants as invaders where to begin
first of all it just is not true what he
said they're not labeling Hispanic
immigrants as invaders their labeling
foreign nationals who illegal illegally
cross into our country as invaders which
they are just by definition not Hispanic
immigrants they're not immigrants
they're foreign nationals they're
illegal aliens they are invaders but
look at what he's doing because this is
really ramping it up it's not just
defaming the president it's not just
hurling a totally vile unfair attack
it's not just being a hypocrite on the
one hand calling for the president to
condemn white supremacy then the next
minute saying you don't welcome his
condemning white supremacy what this is
doing now is threatening regular old
American citizens threatening your own
constituents Joaquin de Castro is saying
is hey it's a nice political donation
you got there sure would be a shame if I
called you a white supremacist for it
from my platform from my taxpayer-funded
platform here in the US Congress he's
intimidating people into not donating to
Republicans by threatening to not quite
docks them he doesn't quite release
their personal information I mean just
by revealing their identities from that
massive national platform surely their
their personal information is now going
to get out this is the age of the
internet everybody's personal
information is everywhere so if you just
call attention to somebody from such a
big stage as that that information is co
- get out functionally it is the same as
daxing but what a vile disgusting thing
to do and the Democrats are not backing
down he's Joaquin Castro is actually
doubling down when called out about this
on MSNBC my post was actually a lament
if you look at my language I said that
it's sad that these folks many of whom
were prominent business owners in San
Antonio a city that's about 65 percent
Hispanic their customers the people that
have made them wealthy their employees
the people that worked for them for
years many of those folks are Hispanic
and they're giving their money to a guy
who's running ads talking about
Hispanics invading this country so it
was a lament about all of us go to the
restaurants these people own the
businesses that they own we patronize
these places and they're giving this
money their money to this guy who's
taking their money and using it to buy
Facebook ads talking about how Hispanics
are invading this country and that there
is a cost to that we saw the cost of
that in El Paso over the weekend that
people died it's so disgusting what he's
doing you see he then left always does
this this guy doxed his own constituents
effectively he at least exposed to them
shamed them and threatened them his own
constituents and then when he gets
called out on this he portrays himself
as the victim oh no I wasn't shaming
them I wasn't threatening them I wasn't
threatening all the other people who
were gonna donate to Republicans I was
lamenting I was just lamenting it's so
sad
gosh I hope I hope no one laments at
Joaquin Castro his home address
would be they'd be lamenting it they'd
be lamenting where Joaquin Castro I hope
no one laments like Maxine Waters
and says we should go to our political
opponents where they live we should mob
them in the streets we should go where
their children sleep
it's a lament okay you're crying Joaquin
it's a lament okay and to lie about it
to lie saying that Republicans are
calling Hispanics invaders not true
he's calling people who invade our
country invaders which they are
so disgusting what a disgusting man his
what what a really vile awful person you
know for the other clips for the other
guys you know Nicole Wallace or or even
Cory Booker those attacks are dishonest
they're corrupt and they're creepy and
they're wrong but but that attack from
Joaquin Castro is so direct because it's
it's on civilians it's on his own
constituents it's such a it's like what
the mob does it's what the gangsters do
it'sit's really awful it demands a
response from Republicans it demands
that we get that we engage in some of
these dirty tactics to hate to do it but
but it demands that response what he's
doing is a vile attack on his own
constituents he said we should be
censured for it he should be removed
from Congress he should be ashamed of
himself
other attacks though have been even more
esoterica this is where you go from the
realm of tragedy to the realm of force
you had the the former FBI director of
counterintelligence come on to MSNBC and
he wasn't talking about he wasn't just
totally making up these normal lies of
calling Hispanics invaders and and
calling Trump a white supremacist he
found the hidden esoteric message so you
thought here's what you thought you
thought that President Trump was
condemning white nationalism and white
supremacy you thought that he said we're
gonna lower the flag to half-mast
because of these tragedies but what this
guy saw with this MSNBC former
counterintelligence FBI guy saw was the
secret hidden esoteric Nazism in
president Trump's remarks
take a listen we have to understand the
adversary and the threat we're dealing
with and if we don't understand how they
think we'll never understand how to
counter them so it's little things and
language and messaging that matters the
president said that we will fly our
flags at half-mast
until August 8th that's eight eight now
I'm not going to imply that he did this
deliberately but I am using it as an
example of the ignorance of the
adversary that's being demonstrated by
the white house the numbers eight a
are very significant in neo-nazi and
white supremacy movement why because the
letter H is the eighth letter of the
alphabet and to them the numbers eight
eight together stand for Heil Hitler
so we're gonna be raising the flag back
up at dusk on eight eight no one's
thinking about this the only true
statement he said there is no one's
thinking about this it's the only
relevant statement he made C President
Trump is lowering the flags to half-mast
but only to put forward his secret
hidden esoteric Hitler message no where
by the way in this coverage you'll
notice do people talk about the other
mass shooting there was one mass
shooting in El Paso that was undertaken
by an eco fascist a radical
environmentalist who also was a racial
bigot and they've pinned that one on the
right they're not talking about the
shooter in Ohio who was an avowed
Elizabeth Warren supporter
how about Joaquin Castro publishes all
the names of Elizabeth Warren's donors
why didn't he do that
those people are donating to the same
person endorsed by the mass shooter in
Ohio
those people are donating to someone who
inspired a mass shooter in Ohio I bet
they published the list of the names of
media matters supporters we look the guy
was reposting a ton of Media Matters
tweets so Media Matters is inspiring
mass shooters right let's publish their
supporters let's publish the people who
have ever said anything positive about a
antifa no they don't talk about that
because that's not politically
convenient to them they need to pretend
that white supremacy white supremacist
terrorism is the biggest biggest problem
in the whole country there were two
shootings over the weekend
half of those shootings were from
radical leftists that's not part of the
conversation Tucker Carlson came out and
and he unambiguously in his typical
Tucker way came out against the hysteria
and blunt terms he pointed out there are
two attacks one of them was from
leftists no one's talking about that he
observed that this whole issue of white
supremacist terror is being totally
singularly HAARP done by the media to
exploit dead Americans for political
ends and he called BS but the whole
thing is a lie if you were to
assemble a list a hierarchy of concerns
of problems this country faces where
would white supremacy be on the list
right up there with Russia probably it's
actually not a real problem in America
the combined membership of every white
supremacist organization in this country
with able to fit inside a college
football stadium I mean seriously this
is a country where the average person is
getting poorer where the suicide rate is
spiking white supremacy that's the
problem this is a hoax
just like the Russia hoax it's a
conspiracy theory used to divide the
country and keep a hold on power that's
exactly what's going on now the left the
typical people on the left like Media
Matters who you'll remember was is an
organization regularly posted about by
the mass shooter in Ohio Media Matters
just reminding you of that a media
matters is going after Tucker trying to
take away his show for saying that the
singular focus on white supremacy is the
biggest problem in America is a hoax
well just look at the numbers the
Guardian out of the UK published an
article just a few days ago showing the
number of how many people had been
killed worldwide over the last eight
years in white nationalists linked
attacks worldwide not just in the United
States last eight years how many people
do you think give you one guess like
what are you gonna say ten thousand five
thousand three thousand two thousand one
hundred seventy five people awful every
one of those deaths is a tragedy but
that's the number those are the data 175
people less than 22 people per year
worldwide killed in white nationalists
linked attacks according to the Guardian
in 2016 there were 45,000 suicides in
the United States alone on average 22
per year people killed in white
nationalists linked attacks worldwide
just one year 45,000 people killed
themselves in the United States alone 33
thousand annual deaths related to guns
in the United States each year between
eight and nine thousand gang-related
homicides just in the United States
obviously what Tucker is saying is
empirically true but the mainstream
media are only focusing on that one
thing Media Matters which I'll remind
you was posted
by the Ohio mass shooter just wanted to
remind you of that Media Matters going
after Tucker Carlson why because
Tucker's a white supremacist of course
not he's not a white supremacist going
after Tucker because he's a white
nationalist of course not he's not a
white nationalist they're going after
Tucker cuz Tucker has a big show and
Tucker has got a big platform and a lot
of people listen to him they're gonna go
after all of us they already are going
after us they go after ben shapiro and
call him a neo-nazi the guy wears a
yarmulke everyday orthodox jew doesn't
matter to them they use this absolutely
outrageous unfair attack to to lump in
all right wingers with an eco fascist
who shot up a mall in el paso texas
because he had some political positions
that might fall in the right-wing camp
he also had some that certainly fall in
the left-wing camp the el paso shooter
said explicitly i was not inspired to do
this by donald trump i held these views
long before donald trump the same group
they lump all of us in they don't
acknowledge that they were retweeted by
the shooter in ohio this the same people
so despicable so shameless that's the
present left the future left gets even
more farcical we'll take a little visit
down to the democratic socialists of
america convention in just a little bit
but first we're gonna bring on our pal
they can serve it through
environmentalist benji backer we are
going to talk about trade and share we
got a whole lot to do we got to take a
break though you are almost out of time
to purchase tickets to our backstage
live show on August 21st at the
incredible Terrace Theatre in Long Beach
California ben shapiro daily wire
god-king jeremy boring andrew Clavin and
myself will be chopping up the winners
and losers of politics and pop culture
best of all we'll be answering your
questions from the audience
tickets are available at daily wire comm
slash backstage and there are still a
few VIP tickets available not many
though they are they are really running
out so make sure if you want to get that
VIP ticket back and you got to go do it
ASAP that includes premium seating
photos and meet and greets with each of
us and the special gift from been among
other things they are selling fast head
over to daily wire comm slash backstage
get yours today go to daily wire comm
we'll be right back with a whole lot
more
all right we are joined now by our pal
Benjy Becker
president of the American conservation
Coalition we talked about red flag laws
at the top of the show we are gonna talk
about green conservatives at the bottom
of the show and maybe Benjy will turn me
into an environmentalist I don't think
it's gonna happen but hope springs
eternal in the human breast Benjy thank
you so much for being here hey it's
great to be here
Benjy you are that rare breed of
individual you're the environmentalist
conservative how many of there are you
you're like the only one that's just not
true I think I would say most
conservatives are environmentalists it's
actually really interesting I go and I
speak to conservative groups all the
time and what they say well I always ask
before the before I get into the speech
who here considers himself an
environmentalist and almost every single
person raises their hands and then I say
who considers themselves an
environmentalist in today's terms not a
single one raises their hands that's the
problem here the environmental movement
has become so politicized that every
conservative doesn't feel like they can
be a part of the discussion even though
they care about the environment just as
much or even more than their leftist
counterparts and I hate to prom for two
reasons one you have one side dominating
the conversation as a result and on the
flip side you have conservatives that
don't propose policy solutions that
aren't engaged as much as the left even
though they care just as much right I
think that's a totally fair distinction
and do conservatives care about the
environment of course we should it's
right there in the word conserve and
I've always considered myself at least a
supporter of conservation or concert but
I I now think with this modern
environmentalist movement it's there is
a difference between the
environmentalists and the
conservationists the conservationists
wanting to preserve nature and its
beauty for us because we love it so much
and environmentalists who you know they
hug trees they think that animals have
rights they seem almost to want to serve
the environment rather than to conserve
it so that that it can serve us but what
is the relationship because I think we
can all get on board with conservation
what is the relationship between that
and global warming which you see
everybody talking about around the
were told that we're either all gonna
die in 14 months or 35 years or a
hundred months or two years ago and
there seems to be so much alarmism
around it that conservatives reflexively
pull away from from that keyword
environmentalism yeah that's so true and
I actually as a millennial and actually
I'm James II technically I started
wearing a watch recently somewhere like
if we only have 14 counting down the
days right but know what that is the
problem is that it's become so
politicized because of climate change
and we're told that we have to change
our entire lives to fix the problem of
global warming or climate change but
what's funny about that is that the
science doesn't even say that if you
look at what the UN and every other kind
of organization nonprofit or government
agency that's put together climate data
says none of them say that we only have
12 months 12 years 15 years to fix this
problem they say that it's a global
problem that we have time to fix it and
it's not gonna ruin our lives overnight
does that mean that we should ignore it
no but that also doesn't mean that we
have to like basically walk to school
every day and walk to work every day
like we are told we have to do and it
but it's been used as a tool of the left
what we work on is it doesn't really
matter if you believe in climate change
or not because at the end of the day
reduced emissions are good for everybody
no one wants pollutants in the air
clogging up the atmosphere with smog or
whatever the pollutants are so it's good
for everyone to reduce emissions so no
matter if you're a climate skeptic a
climate alarmists
or anything in between there is an
incentive to reduce emissions and so I
personally believe in climate change I
don't believe that it's gonna you know
and the world in 12 years or that we
have only 12 years to fix it but
regardless of where you are on the issue
there is an incentive to reduce
emissions but isn't there a cost to it I
mean we're constantly told we need we
have these sweeping laws to reduce
emissions from automobiles that put new
regulations on cars that's why we get
all these like kind of light modern cars
that you know aren't gas guzzlers aren't
those cool cars from the 70s this is a
little bit of a hobby horse of mine and
you know there's obviously a cost to the
economy there are a lot of proposed
like cap-and-trade for for example and
others - that would weigh on business
would weigh on the economy so if we're
not certain that it's going to kill us
all if we're not certain what the effect
of these policies is going to be if the
majority of pollution is coming out of
emerging economies like in China for
instance if even if the United States
radically transformed its economy
wouldn't do a whole lot on the global
scale I mean you saw those reports out
of the Paris climate Accord that that
even if everyone signed on it would only
reduce global the global mean
temperature at a fraction of a degree
over a hundred years then what is the
end goal because this is the whole issue
just seems so blurry to me no one can
tell me what its gonna look like if we
do nothing no one can tell me what the
cost of the emissions is going to be
look specifically what do we want so on
this on the first part of that it is not
impossible to reduce emissions without
it's not impossible to reduce emissions
without bring the size of government
because you you even look at clean
energy today and like Texas is number
two in wind power in the country which
most people don't know because they
think Texas is just the devil state if
they're an environmentalist probably but
at the end of the day it's becoming
cheaper and more cost efficient to use
nuclear wind you know hydro and and it's
solar which are clean energy sources and
so that's taking emissions out of the
air and it's actually more
cost-effective so you've got companies
across the country that are switching to
a hundred percent clean energy and
they're reducing their emissions as a
company because it's cheaper and because
it helps the environment at the same
time so those two things don't have to
the economy the environment don't have
to conflict' despite what the left says
they definitely do not have to but at
the same time what we need to do is in
the United States we lead the globe on
pretty much every issue within history
and so if you look at what we can do in
climate change and reducing emissions we
can use in all the above energy approach
and figure out new technology and
innovation there's this thing called
carbon capture which takes carbon out of
the atmosphere and reuses it for
products which is really really cool and
those are the types of things that we
can give to other nations like China and
India
if we switch to wind and solar overnight
like degree new deal wants us to do none
of those countries would be able to do
that and you're right it would just be a
shot in the dark but if we do something
in the United States like we're already
doing leading the world in emissions
reductions if we continue doing that and
we're able to transfer our technology
and our innovation to other countries
who are still using traditional energy
sources that's the way to curb climate
change and that's the way that the left
won't talk about well fortunately China
already steals all of our technology so
they're probably already stolen our
carbon capture whether or not they'll
implemented I'm a little skeptical
because there's this other side of it
which is we do lead the world and we we
also lead the world in protecting the
environment you know we pulled out of
that Paris climate Accord and then the
report came out that in 2017
we actually led those signatories in
reducing carbon emissions well the
signatories to it not only didn't lower
their emissions they actually increased
their carbon emissions so do we need
these big multinational you know virtue
signaling Accords to fix the environment
or is this more of a local thing
starting with the man in the mirror just
saying we're going to implement this
technology because we want to protect
our lovely beautiful environment I think
I think the latter and what people don't
understand and oftentimes within this
community is that every country is in a
different place
China is in a different place than we
are Europe is in a different place than
we are you can't create a multinational
agreement and just put everybody into
the same box it's like Common Core on
steroids so what it comes down to is the
opportunity for us as a country to show
what we can do with what we have and and
showcase that to other countries and
we're already doing that like you
mentioned seven out of the last ten
years we have led the world in emissions
reduction we haven't done that because
of a Paris Accords we haven't done that
because of a carbon tax we haven't done
that because of cap-and-trade we've done
that because of innovation and
technology does that mean we're done and
that we should stop caring about the
environment that we don't have work to
do no doesn't mean any of that but it
shows that we're on the right track and
it also shows that when you take an
approach we even looking at your own
government and your own economy first
and you look at how you can improve to
that that is the best way to go forward
on
every Environmental Protection and
that's why state parks for example are
way more way better managed than
national parks when you get it lower
down yep as we know is limited
government conservatives it oftentimes
is a lot better and that's the same
thing on the environment a multinational
agreement is way less effective than
United States doing its own actions
state actions are even more efficient
that's just how it goes within the
environmental community but again that's
just something that's not talked about
yeah it's an absolutely correct point
speaking of that issue being talked
about where can people find you yeah so
we are a nonprofit focused on these
issues trying to build the grassroots of
the environmental community within the
conservative community it's a sisi eko
so instead calm its dock eco ACCE eco
and if you're conservative or
libertarian or moderate who cares about
the environment we're the home for you I
like that a sisi eko I want a dot eco
website that seems like Michael knows
eco I wanted to stand for economics
though baby give me all that sweet sweet
money and then I guess I could be a
green Republican to Bengie thank you so
much for being here man we gotta let you
go but check it out a CC dot eco I also
follow you on twitter always love your
love your tweets so check them out there
Benjy backer Benjy will we'll talk to
you soon
all right speaking of China by the way
before we get to these wacky socialists
in America I do want to point out we
mentioned the the escalating trade war
with China yesterday CNN has a headline
today which shockingly is correct and I
know you know look a broken clock twice
a day is Right CNN points out today that
China has a 1.1 trillion dollar weapon
in trade right now that they may or may
not use I hope they don't use it but
they very well might and that 1.1
trillion dollar weapon is they buy up
our debt and so they buy up all of our
debt they are America's biggest creditor
so in theory if China wanted to they
could trigger a panic in bond markets by
dumping some of their US Treasuries that
they have I've mentioned this just to
remind people that trade is a much
bigger issue than partisans and
ideologues on both sides are trying to
make it out to be there are some people
who say
free trade all the time no argument for
tariffs no argument to keep
manufacturing in your own country and
then there are some some people on the
other side who are who have been saying
for years and years we need it we only
need economic protection we got to keep
our jobs here we got a we don't need to
trade with the rest of the world you
know I think unfortunately the camp in
the primary camp is the larger one but
it's much more complicated than that
you know if tariffs are always evil why
does everybody have them if a trade war
with China is just invariably terrible
or there are other costs or they're you
know why would China buy up all of our
debt why does China want all of this
manufacturing why does China devalue its
currency to increase their trade deficit
or their trade surplus rather if trade
deficits and trade surpluses don't
matter why is China made such a
concerted effort to exacerbate that
trade deficit obviously this is much
more complicated it involves a lot more
than cheap Chinese goods we all want
cheap goods we all as consumers want
cheap goods but there is more to life
there is more to the economy there is
more to politics than consumerism so I
don't think I mean just to remind you a
little bit of the timeline here China
has been since 2001 since it entered the
World Trade Organization
they have been breaking the law they
have been illegally subsidizing your
steel and aluminum they've been stealing
our intellectual property they've been
levying hidden taxes on US companies by
forcing those companies to work with
local banks there that add no value they
just simply take money they it's just an
extortion racket they have been spying
on us
putting spyware in our technology and
they've been illegally manipulating
their currency to exacerbate that trade
deficit and to keep the exports flowing
out of China
we now responded to that under President
Trump first time we've gotten serious on
it in a long time by by levying tariffs
and then just this week by the Treasury
Department labeling China a currency
manipulator now we're gonna see what
China is going to do for that are they
going to back down or are they going to
go really hard or are they going to say
sell off their US Treasuries a sell off
of their I don't think the sell off a
few US Treasuries is going to happen
because it would under
China's desire to attract foreign
investment but all of this is to say we
are in a trade war that has been a long
time coming we it is not avoidable it is
not just the stupidity of President
Trump or the inability of President
Trump to under understand the wonders of
free trade we don't currently have a
legal free trade relationship with China
this has been building for almost two
decades
Trump is finally doing something about
it we should gear up we should buckle up
because it has to happen for the
long-term health of the United States
speaking of crazy socialists not just in
China but in the United States you know
you look around at the present left the
candidates running for president and the
people on television and you think gosh
this is pretty bad because I am both an
optimist and a pessimist
I I want to tell everybody who thinks
things couldn't get any worse oh yes
they can
looking at our universities looking at
the young activists looking at the
Democratic socialists of America things
are going to get a whole lot wackier
just take a little glimpse at the
grievances that the DSA is having at
their national convention quick pointer
privilege once again hi James Jackson
Sacramento TSA he/him I have already
asked people to be mindful of the
chatter of their comrades who are
sensitive to sensory overload and that
goes double for the heckling and the
hissing it is also triggering to my
anxiety like the bee comradely doesn't
just isn't just for like you know let's
keep things civil or whatever it's so
that people aren't gonna get triggered
and so that it doesn't affect their
performance as a delegate okay your need
to express yourself is important but you
need to express yourself you should not
Trump or over like I can't wait until
that guy's a congressman congressman
trigger the Democrat representing I
don't know probably a OCS district in
about 10 or 20 years there gonna be a
lot of rules too I mean they could
barely even get started with all the
triggering comments because of all the
rules just let just a little glimpse of
some of the regulations the DSA imposes
on their own conference we have quiet
rooms that are available there's a range
of options of these right one thing to
note there please don't go into that
space
that's like an aggressive scent for
instance right
first and foremost use the proper doors
don't try and exit through these or any
other sort of like fun shortcuts you see
um you have to have your credentials at
all time there are right-wing
infiltrators who are trying to get in
here and generally try to be chill right
take a deep breath feel better before
you say anything please don't tweet
photos of your credentials if you have
friends here that you would like to be
here they don't have credentials don't
let them in don't make exceptions for
those people don't really talk to
anybody who doesn't have a pretend
credential especially if they claim to
be from the press please do not talk to
anybody who identifies themselves as a
member of the press don't talk to cops
don't talk to Magga don't talk to cops
if there are cops there for any reason
at all right you do see someone talking
to cops let the marshals know okay did
you get all that did you get all the
things you cannot do you can't do it
that's gonna be the Democratic
socialists of America you can't do that
that's gonna be their campaign slogan
get used to it folks I mean we should
enjoy the glory days of right now when
they're just trying to take away our our
cars and our airplanes and our cows and
our houses because these guys a OC is
moderate compared to the future
Democratic socialists of America gear up
for the end of our politics okay that's
our show yeah a lot more to get to but
we'll do it tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles Oh see you then
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico our audio mixer is
Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup by Jesuit
Elvira production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today as we rush headlong into social
unrest and and worse there are people
who seem to be trying to speed up the
process we'll discuss that also a white
supremacist attacked me for opposing
white supremacy and so I will respond to
that stupid bigoted today and feminists
are concerned that women don't talk
enough is that really a problem in this
culture of ours I don't think so but
we'll try to get to the bottom of that
today - on the Matt Walsh show